another review that hit the site real
soon
mmm a wonderful game by the name of
pokken tournament has just got a 9 out
of 10 on GameSpot calm and did I
pronounce that one right Peter brand yes
you said that as though I hope you been
poking me about my pronunciation do I
know
you sit so far away my I can't mister I
I'm just transitioning back from Ireland
mode as well so I'm saying all my words
wrong one two tree at pokken tournament
9 out of 10 tomorrow stain review -
story saying its first review for us oh
really
I know he's been around for a good while
- 9 out of 10 it's a fighting game it is
a fighting it is a 3d fighting game it
is a 3d slash 2d fighting game ok so in
the red like Tekken and Wat nosh I know
Tekken is 3d ok so in the middle of a
battle if you do a certain amount of
damage or you perform a certain move it
goes from this sort of 3d all-range mode
to a 2d planar Pokemon are fighting sort
of similar to Street Fighter well cool
move back and forth then you can break
out of that again go back to the field
phase so you've been playing a bunch of
this as well you obviously didn't review
of items but I have played a bunch I'm
not currently playing it anymore
she's a lot going on but the game is
really fun when I sat down there for the
first time I had sort of looked at it as
one of those Naruto fighting games
because they kind of just resembled it
like I never really general like broad
level but one it's a little bit
different because it has those two
phases but also as someone who's like
Pokemon over the years and it continues
to kinda like it but my appreciations
been waning maybe a little bit this was
like ok wow I actually have control over
Pokemon directly and as 12 points out
like you're interacting with these
Pokemon in real time like against each
other it actually feels like you would
imagine a Pokemon battle would be
because it's what I mean yeah we like
collecting Pokemon and I guess fighting
in them is kind of fun but really
there's you know saying like Pikachu do
a lightning bolt like yeah it's not that
fun to actually just like do the light
and blows Pikachu right and then keep
going keep fighting and not waiting your
turn so that many other reasons the
game's really good
are there still humans shedding orders
at you no not anymore no so you do and
Yolo he's just like whatever I'm a
Pokemon I'm free yeah you know it feed
me puffins anymore
you puff I was there yeah like a
miniature penguin yeah I'm just
misinterpreting a very funny YouTube
video from a couple years oh he also
mentioned in his review lots of like
mode variety which is somebody who
bought Street Fighter 5 and they're
frustrated fighting Panem lack of mode
variety thank you ah yeah that sounds
interesting to me so is there a loads of
ways to play this game multiplayer and
singleplayer is loads fair is fair I
mean you've got definitely some and and
I know that the story or whatnot because
you sort of just like climb a ladder
it's like climbing a tower immortal all
right you know that that kind of thing
is shanks owned at the top yeah okay
goro no she's not Pokemon could be a
Pokemon no yeah I mean honestly there
aren't that many modes but there's at
least two modes you would expect let's
put it that way
ultra jari says in the twitch shot how
many pokemons are there in pokken 16 we
oughta catch them all
yeah not easier 60 17 if you get shadow
me to you and then it that's like your
core set right and then you still have
your assist pokémon as well so it's an
assist pokémon
so Jigglypuff yeah you sort of like
there's a meter that recharges and you
can call them in and they do an attack
that either like well hurt the enemy or
impair them in some way like Jacob
health dude yes put him asleep well
Julie post out there Thomas it's also
annoying heal that Randy was using on me
a lot what was that well one of the
assists heals you so he's like man he's
like you could have that to Eric I'm
like yeah I could but is the the roster
selection which like forget about how
they look like whatever they all play
fine but when I'm looking at the list
it's like there's a chandelier Pokemon
as one of the main fighters like there
are 721 Pokemon at this point surely
there are ones better suited than a
frickin chandelier man yeah how did
chandelier never come up in all like the
the many what's the dumbest Pokemon
segments we have done on the lobby oh
because there are 721 Pokemon there's
Goro
there's goro fighting right there that's
my champ hey man chandelier Pokemon I
don't know his name but it's probably
Shawn da da
he needed a time this was one of those
times you know he's gonna get a time to
shine now you're gonna remember him for
the rest of your life yeah they said
that there's no plans for DLC right now
but I'm calling BS on that gold mines
gonna be for them ever there was a game
right for DLC oh there you go it's a
chandelier Pokemon God cast feel free to
Google chandelier Pokemon and I'm sure
this is the first one little pocket Bob
it kind of looks like the Neil as well I
will say I will say the games like super
super accessible yeah like anyone can
play and like have fun but it's it seems
like it can get pretty deep too because
you know there's counter attacks kind of
like a focus attack and Street Fighter
it's gonna be a TiVo so you know there's
that gonna be an Evo like legit or
they're doing them paid for you know
it's one of the ten games this year
it's one of these games it's like double
digit but it's gonna be there just you
wait
high level high level pokken tournament
I mean you know there is room for it
like if there's high-level smash play
I'd say it's fair to say that there
could be high-level poke and play right
it's just like the barrier to like
perform a certain move is much easier
than something like Street Fighter
because it's just a direction in a
button right yeah Tamar said it was kind
of easy like a good sort of quick one to
get into people don't play fighting
games
yeah apps like I love them pokemons I
love them all catch it I die by the
pillow case can you get Pikachu like
pillows like love pill you know sleeping
pillows like I know John boyega wife was
the guy what was the Goro guy much um
for China thank you got like a match on
a Jigglypuff works for arms jean-yves
opposite you asleep so if I could just
hug there's a chloroform in there really
good you can have that for free Pokemon
company that was cool yeah someone's on
it right now
hey we just heard a great idea and the
good cheer 71 five said this is not
directly related to Pokemon okay do you
have any info of one HTC vive will
on the GDC or valves the lab game I'd
love to answer that question glasses
Christ about 7,000 times in the chat
there you go okay the lab I don't know
have you seen the lab yet
the lab Oh a thing I think that's a it
sounds familiar I'm not sure what it is
I'm so I'm so confused
as soon as put in all the games that
were Evo this year Street Fighter 5
Super Mario Bros u can't them right
Street Fighter 5 Super Mario Bros fight
goombas Street Fighter 5 Super Mario
Street Fighter 5 super smash bros melee
yeah so super tries to merge into Super
Smash Bros 4 Wii U yeah there's melee
and we use so it's to size 303 total no
guilty here or whatever well combine X
yep don't give it to you ki ultimate
amber vs. Capcom 3 yeah um you see three
it was also a show that I watched as a
youth where this old man would give
science projects to little kids they mr.
wizard yeah and if they screwed up he
would like let me show you how to do it
just do what kid you know what could be
tense but they're definitely not gonna
do it and people actually wanted it it
was Ultra Street Fighter 4 all right but
they're not they're definitely not doing
that just because Capcom would not want
that the next platform man you gotta get
pushed that can we talk about the sales
of Street Fighter 5 real quick sure how
you 100,000 worldwide oh god they wanted
2 million by mark yeah yeah that's
really bad Wow I was looking at the
Steam what's called again I don't know
the steam stats thing I always look it's
called it's like the one that like
tracks all and the PC sales were not
that great the first two weeks it's bad
it's just super street fighter for an
update to the existing game sold more in
its first few weeks this new Street
Fighter 5 did you just don't want to
launch a game broken anymore or launched
again I only think it was the climate
surrounding the game like when it came
out I just feel like people were still
okay mystery flavor for when four came
out we didn't have anything like it for
years and if five shows up and it's sort
of like yeah like superficially right
from the outside looking in it's like I
don't really know what I'm getting
that's any different yeah just looks
like yeah 3d Street Fighter in a 2d
playing okay I get it
well also with Street Fighter 5 I
remember a while back ago they're like
oh yeah five is not coming out for a
while like 2017
surprise no it was right after they
started they did that merge with Sony or
they got that kind of like that deal was
it was a push right yeah yeah that was
when they kind of made the push up like
oh yeah this is happening like there's a
lot sooner when is the big March update
coming for that at the end of the month
okay
April update I'll see how I'm so
concerned have you seen how they're
going to try and combos rage critters oh
by having people publicly shame them
they like recording them on a woman by
one basis yeah they need people to like
say when it happens they're going to go
back and review like the tape and then
like get rid of they're like yeah what
do we do currently feel comfortable
styling up to your game you know like
can you blame like a thirteen-year-old
kid who like like doesn't want to lose
and signs off it's not like we're all
grown adults playing yes stuff and we
need to be shamed I think kids gonna
feel bad and he's probably not gonna
want to play anymore if Capcom publicly
calls him out no that's how you teach
him a lesson that's why you don't rage
quit that's how your kids yeah you know
rage play fair
you sit there and you look like photos
of your kids on the fridge every time
they rage quit let's use like an analogy
right like do you hate suddenly shifted
gears to mr. wizard
for the podcast listeners this is a
gentleman who seems to be cooking sink
egg in front of a gormless child you
just know the slightest thing about
thermodynamics you really need the audio
because kids he's like no idiot if
you've listened to what I just said mr.
wizard was before the internet eva's
before the Internet which was his time
yeah this show was the best casting
tanum I was gonna say though I think
about I mean I don't know if you would
publicly shame them but let's say you're
playing a game rocket League right like
let's say I go forward I'm down for one
with about two and a half to three
minutes left
yeah Andy Bauman was infamous for
wanting to forfeit right away which is
the essentially a rage quit right
without closing application like no
we're not doing that yet even if he
thinks that they're better than us right
like team would get the points is the
thing there's that rage quitting you
don't win either do you I don't like
yeah you just got nothing it just kind
of like kicks you out a lot but that's
beside the point it's the principle yeah
you don't princess do that that's why
you gotta get change which is a
publisher slash developer be calling
people out matter no let us know what
you think in the comments below